FEMALE SPEAKER: Please
join me in
welcoming Mr. Kenneth Cukier.
[APPLAUSE]
KENNETH CUKIER: Thank
you very much.
You can probably appreciate the
fact that I've got a lot
of trepidation coming here to
talk to you folks for the
obvious reason that I'm
wearing a suit.
And the truth is I had a
breakfast this morning at the
Council on Foreign Relations
to talk to them about the
international implications
and the foreign-policy
implications of big data.
That leads to the second
trepidation and the context of
my remarks.
So the second trepidation is
that this is a sort of
homecoming for the book.
Because my journey, so to speak,
in the world of big
data started at Google
and started at the
Googleplex in 2009.
It was you folks who opened up
the kimono to what you were
doing in very small
little slivers.
I never got the full picture.
But I was able to cobble it all
together and see something
and then give it
a label to it.
Luckily, there was a couple
of labels that we
were thinking of.
And I reached for one that
wasn't a popular term at the
time, and the term
was big data.
And that was really helpful.
It was the cover story
of "The Economist"
in February of 2010.
It was called "The Data Deluge",
because they thought
they would sell it better
than saying "big
data." But big data--
it was basically all about
that and about what
you guys are doing.
And so it brings me great fear
to walk into a room, because
you guys have been doing
it for so long.
And that brings me into
the context of my
conversation today.
I want it to be a
conversation.
I was obviously just at the
Council on Foreign Relations
thinking about this in ways that
I am sure your engineers
never thought about
it 10 years ago.
I may have heard a snort.
But here's the thing.
Many of you were thinking of
it as a technological issue
when people around the world
think of it in terms of the
competitivity of nations.
Our book, which is being
released today in America, has
already been available in
China, where it's been a
best-seller.
And when we hear questions from
Chinese journalists to
us, they're all talking about
the national project that
they're on.
Is this the way for us to
leapfrog with the West?
Is this one area of technology,
unlike the
internet and computing,
where we can lead?
So the implications
of this are vast.
And the implications are more
than just technological.
I'm at a technology company-- in
fact, the pioneer, in many
respects, of big data.
But I want to explain that I'm
here as a journalist, as
someone who's looked in at your
world and now can serve
as a sort of a filter.
And what I'd like to do is show
you that world from a
non-engineer's perspective,
from someone who just is
curious about the world and
society and thinks deeply
about these issues.
Now there's a second disclosure
I have to make, and
that is not only am I talking
about big data, but my
presentation is big data.
Because there's 70 slides.
On top of it, I haven't actually
really seen the
slides except for once or
twice, because they just
arrived to my inbox this morning
from someone who was
putting it together for me.
This is actually the recipe for
disaster, so please have
forbearance.
I'm going to go really quickly,
and I'm probably
going to skip through a couple
of these slides.
So let me start with a story,
and the story is the story of
a company called Farecast.
And it begins in
the year 2003.
A guy named Oren Etzioni at the
University of Washington
is on an airplane.
And he asks people how much
they paid for the seats.
And it turns out, of course, for
one person paid one fare,
and one person paid
another fare.
But this made Oren Etzioni
really, really upset.
And the reason why is that he
took the time to book his air
ticket long in advance, figuring
he was going to pay
the least amount of money.
Because that's the way
the system worked.
And then he realized actually
that that wasn't the case.
When he figured that out,
he was really upset.
And he figured, if only I could
knew what is the meaning
behind airfare madness.
How would I know if a price I'm
being presented with at an
online travel site is a
good one or a bad one?
And then he came up
with the insight.
Because he's like you-- he's
a computer scientist--
he realized actually--
that's actually just an
information problem.
And I bet I can get
the information.
All I would need is
one simple thing--
the flight price record of
every single flight in
commercial aviation in the
United States for every single
route, every flight, and to
identify every seat, and to
identify how long in advance the
ticket was bought for the
departure, and what price was
paid, and just run it through
a couple computers, and then
make a prediction on whether
the price is likely to rise or
fall, and score my degree of
confidence in the prediction.
Pretty simple.
So he scraped some data.
And it works pretty well.
And he runs a system.
It's great.
The academic paper that he
writes is called "Hamlet--
To Buy or Not To Buy, That Is
the Question." It works well,
but then he realizes, hey, this
works so well, I'm going
to get more data.
And he gets more data, until he
has 20 billion flight-price
records that he's crunching
to make his prediction.
And now it works really well.
Now it's saving customers
a lot of money.
It gets a little bit of
traction, and Microsoft comes
knocking on the door.
He's in Washington.
He sells it for about
$100 million--
not bad for a couple years work,
and a couple PhDs in
computer science that was
working with him.
But behind this, the
key thing is this.
He took data that was generated
for one purpose and
reused it for another.
When the Sabre database--
at the time probably the airline
reservation system and
one of the biggest, actually the
biggest civilian computer
project at its time when
it was created in
the '50s and '60s--
was created by American
Airlines and IBM.
They never imagined for a
million years that the data of
the passenger manifest was
going to become the raw
material for a new business, and
a new source of value, and
a new form of economic
activity.
And we're going to be creating
markets with this data.
And if you want to understand
what big data is, at least
from a person looking
into it--
because Google's been doing
big data for a long time.
What we're seeing across society
is what you folks have
been doing for years.
We're seeing that data
is becoming a new
raw material of business.
It is the oil, if you will, of
the information economy.
There's a lot of data around
in the world today.
You know this.
The arresting statistics
are obvious.
Whenever we put on a big
new sky survey--
telescope for you and
me-- goes online.
Whenever it goes online, it
usually ends up collecting as
much data in the first night
or two as in the history of
astronomy prior to
it going online.
And obviously, the human
genome, et cetera.
You all know the data about big
data, so I won't spend too
much time there.
But what we see behind big data
are three features of
society, or shifts in the
way that we think about
information in the world--
more, messy, and correlations.
So more.
We're going from an environment
where we've always
been information-starved--
we've never had enough
information--
to one where we-- that's
no longer the operative
constraint.
It's still a constraint.
Of course, we never have
all the information.
What is information?
Is it really the real thing?
But what's clear is that instead
of having to optimize
our tools to presume that we can
only have a small sliver
of information, when
that changes, we
can get a lot more.
And so what does more mean?
Well, think of it as 23andMe.
What they do is they actually
take a sample of your DNA, and
they look for very
specific traits.
Now that works well, but
it's imperfect as well.
That's one reason why
it's only $100--
a couple hundred dollars.
When Steve Jobs had cancer,
he was one of the first
individuals in the world to
have his entire genome
sequenced and his tumor
sequenced as well.
So he had personalized
medicine, and it was
individually tailored
to the state of his
health at that time.
When one drug would work,
they'd continue.
When the cells mutated and
blocked the drug from working,
they routed around it and
tried something else.
They were able to do that
because they had all of the
data, not just some
of the data.
And that's one of the shifts
that we're seeing
from some to more.
And in some cases, n equals
all the data.
We also have messy data.
That's another feature
as well.
In the past, we had highly
curated databases--
information that we optimized
our tools to get in the most
pristine way as possible.
And this was sensible.
When there's only a small amount
of information that you
can bother collecting and
processing, because the cost
is so high and it's so
cumbersome, you have to make
sure the information
you get is the best
possible thing you can.
But when you can avail yourself
of orders and orders
of magnitude more information,
that constraint goes away.
And suddenly, you can allow for
a little bit of messiness.
Now, it can't be completely
wrong.
But messiness is good.
You folks are pioneers of this
in machine translation.
And you know the famous Peter
Norvig, and Allen Harvey, and
others' paper on the
unreasonable
effectiveness of data.
The idea here is that machine
translation worked actually--
was a real step up.
When IBM tried it in around '56
with 20 Russian phrases
and English phrases that they
programmed the computer to
translate, it looked
impressive.
It was ridiculous, of course.
We now know.
It's like a punch card.
Then when IBM's project Candide
came around in the
'90s, actually that was not
machine translation.
That was statistical machine
translation.
That was really good,
relatively speaking.
What they did is they took
the Canadian Hansard--
the parliamentary transcripts
that were translated into both
English and into French--
and they just let the computer
make the inferences of when a
word in French, and it would be
a useful substitute for the
one in English.
They didn't try to
presume what was
right or what was wrong.
They let the computer infer
that itself and score the
probability that one would be
the right word or not in that
particular context,
and go forward.
C-Change--
they tried to optimize it
and make it better.
Couldn't.
Couldn't at a reasonable way.
It just was--
it was a hard problem.
Then Google came along.
And you guys didn't avail
yourself of just the
parliamentary transcripts in
French and English in Canada.
You availed yourself of
the World Wide Web.
It wasn't 1994.
It was 2006.
You poured in.
You got all of the
European Union
translations of all 21 languages.
Your Google Books project became
a signal for what was
good and not because of the
translations that you could
find in the libraries.
Now in many instances, the data
was far less clean than
in the past when we tried
to do it with just a
small amount of data.
But the fact is more data
beat clean data.
Messiness was good.
And the final point, which is
obvious, is correlations.
We have had a society in which
we've always looked for causes
behind things, and that
made sense in a
small-data world as well.
In fact, causality is still
very useful to know.
But for a lot of the problems
that we're dealing with these
days, just knowing the
correlation is good enough.
And in fact, what we're finding
is that often we think
we see causality
when we don't.
And it's hard to do.
So there's going to be cases
where we actually still want
to know the reasons why.
But often, just knowing what is
good enough, because we can
learn the correlation
and go with that.
So a similar company like
Farecast is Decide.com.
This is Oren Etzioni's company
again that basically looks
across the web at all of the
prices online, not just of
airlines, but of anything that
has lots of price data and
high variability and just ranks
it to say, is this a
good price or not?
And it leads to new markets.
It leads to transparency, which
is good for customers.
More interestingly is what this
means for human health.
Premature babies, known
as preemies.
In the past, when we thought
about health care, we would
take the vital signs of someone
maybe once or twice a
day, couple more times if
it was important enough.
And a doctor would look at the
clipboard at the edge of the
bed and make a decision
on what to do.
Feedback loop was really,
really long.
Very, very imperfect.
What we're now able to do-- some
researchers in Canada are
doing this, is they're looking
at the real-time flow of 16
different streams of vital signs
of premature babies.
And they're able to score
it and look for
correlations with it.
And when they do that, they find
that they can spot the
onset of infection 24 hours
before overt symptoms appear.
By doing that, that means that
you can have an intervention
sooner, see if the interventions
working better,
react to it, and save lives.
But you learn something
else as well.
You would have thought-- and you
can imagine generations of
doctors looking at the
clipboard, seeing the kid's
vitals stabilizing, and thinking
it was safe to go
home to supper, that things were
OK, and we'll treat the
patient tomorrow.
Just nurse, call me if
there's a problem.
And then to get a frantic call
at midnight saying something
had gone horribly wrong.
The fact is, what we're finding
is that one of the
best predictors that there is
going to be an onset of an
infection is that the baby's
vital signs stabilize.
Weird, right?
Why?
We don't actually really know
why, what's happening
biologically.
It kind of seems like the kid's
little organs are just
battening down the hatches
for a rough night ahead.
We don't know why, but we know
that with that correlation, we
can do something better.
We can save its life.
And we didn't know that
before big data.
Behind this is we have data.
Why do we have data?
Well, we're collecting more
data for things that we've
always collected data on.
Weather--
great.
That's fantastic.
But it also is because we're
collecting things that was
always informational but we
never treated as data
before, like you.
So you're all sitting.
You're sitting down.
And you are sitting different
than you, and you,
and you, and you.
You weigh different.
Your legs are different.
Your posture is different.
The distribution of weight.
And you know that if I have 20
sensors on your seat and on
your seat back that I can
probably score with a high
degree of accuracy who you are
based on the way you sit.
Why is that useful?
Well, for one purpose, you can
imagine that this would be a
great anti-theft tool in cars.
Put this in, and suddenly you
would know that the authorized
driver of your Lamborghini
is you, and
it's not someone else.
Or if you have children,
likewise, hey, I told you you
can't take the car out
after 10:00 PM.
And so the engine didn't work
when you tried to sit down and
turn the keys in the ignition.
That's great.
But what else can
you do with it?
Well, think about it.
If everybody has their car seat
instrumentized and you
actually datify posture,
suddenly you would be able to,
perhaps, identify the telltale
signs of a shift in posture 30
seconds prior to an accident.
The probability of you getting
into an accident by a shift in
your posture.
Maybe what we've datafied
is driver fatigue.
And the service here would
be the car would
send an internal alarm.
Maybe the steering wheel would
vibrate, or there'd be a chime
saying, hey, wake up.
You have a high likelihood
of getting into an
accident right now.
That's the sort of thing that
is left to play for as we
data-ize society in a
world of big data.
So what we're seeing
is lots of things
being datafied as well.
Facebook datafies our
friendships; Twitter, our
stray thoughts, our whispers;
LinkedIn, our
professional contacts.
Google datafies our
intentions.
So obviously, Google Flu Trends
is a wonderful way to
have a predictor of what
the likelihood of
outbreaks of flu are.
Now that's great.
It's just you don't want to
have to know causality.
You don't know why.
It just is what it is.
Now you may recall that there
was a little bit of a grumble
in the scientific community
recently when they said, the
CDC this year said that flu was
going to be right here--
CDC, the Center of
Disease Controls.
And Google Flu Trends
like this, it
didn't work this year.
Bullshit.
How do we know?
Because CDC is reported data.
The person came in.
Maybe because of the economic
crisis, people decided they
had to show up at work and
didn't go see a doctor.
Maybe the Google Flu Trends
is accurate, and
that's what's real.
And CDC is just reported
data, not observed
behavior, isn't as good.
No one thought of that.
Big data has been with
us for a while.
It turns out that there was an
American commodore who had
data-ized all of the old
log books inside of
the dusty Navy trunks.
And with that, he was able to
create a whole new form of
nautical map that told sailors
not just where they were but
the patterns of the winds.
No one realized that the world,
and the winds, and the
waves conformed to
natural patterns.
If you will, that the sea had
its own physical geography,
and that if you [? allided ?]
yourself with those things,
that you could have
a safer voyage.
And we can do that now.
But the problem is it took him
a decade and dozens of people
to do it, and we do the same
sort of thing in about one
sixth of a second every day.
So it's a democratization play
of techniques that we have
tried to do in the past.
We've done sometimes.
Obviously, censuses have been
around since Jesus was born.
But now we're actually doing
it in a widespread way.
Predictive maintenance is a
good example of taking the
same idea about premature
babies and
applying it to machines.
When your car is about to break
down, it doesn't go
kaput all at once.
Usually, you can feel it.
There's a grumble, or it just
doesn't drive right.
Well, now what we can do is
instrumentize it, see what the
data signature of the heat and
the vibration is, find out how
it correlates with previous
incidences of a break down,
and know, perhaps, two days in
advance that your fan belt is
going to break.
And that's happening today in
fleets of cars by UPS, and
it's going to be in your
car tomorrow if
it's not already there.
The value of data is hidden.
It's hidden not in the primary
purpose for what it was
collected for.
But now with big-data
techniques, it's often
uncovered in its multiple
secondary uses that are just
limited by our imagination.
So INRIX is a car company that
takes the sat-nav system and
makes a prediction on how long
it's going to take from one
place to another.
Sounds great.
It's a good service.
Use it.
It's also used by economists
to understand
the health of economies.
Because they see how cars drive,
and the frequency and
propensity of cars, and the
travel times as a proxy, an
indicator, for the health of
a local municipal economy.
Hedge funds use this information
to look at the car
circulation in the areas near
a retailer on the weekends.
And so prior to the quarterly
announcements, they have a
good indicator whether the sales
are going to increase or
decrease, and they can short
or go long on its shares.
No one would have thought of
that in the past, that we
could do that sort of thing
with information.
Obviously, everything that we
do-- all of our interactions--
give off lots of data exhaust.
You folks are experienced with
that, because you treat all of
the interactions of an
individual who goes to your
website as a signal for
something else.
You've built your systems and
optimized it based on that
form of data exhaust, by
treating information as a new
raw material that you can
recycle back into the system
to improve it or to create a
whole new system altogether.
There is going to be winners and
losers in this new world.
There's three features that
seem to be distinguishing
who's going to do well.
And that's the skills, the
mindset, and the data.
The skills are kind
of obvious.
It's the people who have
technical knowledge, or it's
the vendors who sell
you stuff.
That's great.
The mindset, in some ways, seems
to be more important.
Because what you need is
not just the skills.
That gets commoditized
first, obviously.
History of computing
suggested that.
The first computer scientists
in the '50s and '60s--
actually, not the scientists.
But these were the doers, the
software programmers.
They looked like they were
sitting pretty wearing the
white lab coats.
But by the '70s and '80s, man,
just an ordinary rinky-dink
software developer had been
largely commoditized.
And we're going to see that
with big data as well.
Today, some companies and people
are at the high end.
It's going to filter
through as the PhD
programs get forward.
The mindset is going to be
critical and the creativity.
But ultimately, both of
those things are going
to go to the wayside.
Because if you remember, Jeff
Bezos had a great dot-com
mindset really early in '94
or so, and he executed
brilliantly as well.
But by the 2000, every
executive was
thinking about the web.
So we're going to have the
same thing with big data.
That advantage doesn't
hold that long.
The data, however-- who has
access to the data is going to
be critical.
That's the resource.
So weirdly, and ironically,
what seems to be abundant
today is actually the source of
scarcity, and vice versa.
Now in New York, we
have a problem
with overcrowded buildings.
But before I tell you that
story, let me see much time we
have, because I want to
get questions as well.
I think we're doing OK.
So tenements, overcrowded
buildings, and the problem of
just stuffing 10 times as many
occupants into a single
dwelling as it was
designed for.
This is a bad thing, and
it's a bad thing
because it leads to crime.
It leads to drugs.
It leads to violence.
And it leads to fires, and not
just any kind of fires.
Basically, these kind of fires
kill the occupants.
And they also end up injuring
and killing at much greater
rates the firefighters who
go to help it out.
So this is a serious problem
for the city.
The city gets something like
63,000 calls a year for
complaints of illegal,
overcrowded stuffing in buildings.
And there's only 200 inspectors
at City Hall.
So there you see a problem.
But the problem is actually
a big-data problem.
How can we solve it?
Well, the first thing that they
do is they take a list, a
database of every single
building in Manhattan and the
five Boroughs, and that's
900,000, give or take.
And then they look at everything
as a signal,
whether it's going to be a
predictor that the thing is
going to burst into flames, or
that it's going to actually
improve the model by predicting
that it's not going
to burst into flames.
So they look at things like
ambulance calls, utility cuts.
Has there been a lean against
the property?
Is there complaints of
rodent infestation?
So the number of rats in the
building is not datafied, but
complaints to the city's
311 line is.
So you find out the number
of rodent complaints.
And all together,
you look at it.
And you can score with a high
degree that the building's
going to burst into flame.
They looked at weird stuff, from
like the Department of
Building Works on whether
exterior brickwork had been
recently done to the building.
That improved the model too.
Because if brickwork was done
to the building, even if you
had all these other problems
that were high indicators of a
fire, it went down.
When they pressed go on the
system, now what happens is an
inspector, instead of going
in-- and about 15% of the
times they would make a visit.
In the past, they would issue
a vacate order, the stiffest
sanction which basically says,
everyone out in 24 hours.
Before it was 15% of the
time-- a high rate.
So it tells you there's
a big problem.
Now it's 70% of the time.
And so what that means is that
they like it, the inspectors,
because it's more effective.
The fire department likes it,
because their firemen aren't
dying as much.
And it's just good for all of
us in our communities to see
that people have good housing
and that these buildings don't
catch on fire.
And that was because they turned
the problem into a big
data problem and solved it
successfully with information.
And they gave up trying to
figure out the causality and
just went with the
correlation.
There, of course, are serious
issues of big data.
One is going to be privacy.
It's a problem now in
the small-data era.
It's going to be a bigger
problem with big data.
But there's going to be
something on top of that.
And that is not privacy,
but propensity--
but prediction.
The idea is that we're going to
have algorithms predicting
our likelihood to do things,
our behavior.
And it's going to be obvious
that we're going to have
governments try to-- or our
businesses sanction us on the
basis of that prediction.
It's going to look a little bit
like "Minority Report" and
the idea of pre-crime.
We're going to be denied a loan,
because we're going to
not have the likelihood
to repay.
But instead of this profiling
universe in which we take us
as a big clump--
and we have a small-data
problem.
Here are the 13 predictors, and
this is the explicit rules
by which we can tell
you the formula.
Imagine if we have
1,000 variables.
It's a machine learning
algorithm, and when we try to
knock on the door in front of a
court and say, I was denied
surgery because you said I had
a 90% mortality rate after
five years with my individual
data, I want you to disclose
to me how you came
to that decision
because that seems unfair.
They're going to say
I don't know.
I can show you the formula.
I've frozen every instantiation
of the data at
every moment, because regulators
required me to.
If I printed out the formula,
it would be on 600 pages.
You need a PhD to
understand it.
It's true you have only 40
strong signals, but you've got
a long tail of 600 weak signals
that all went into it.
I can't tell you why.
And then the person's going to
say, OK, I don't even care
about that.
What makes you think I'm not
going to be part of the 10%
that's going to live
past 10 years?
Why are you denying me this
operation because you think
I've got a high probability of
not surviving longer after it?
I want to take the test.
And you can imagine with
criminal-justice systems, it's
going to be the exact
same thing.
This is the issue
that we have.
And so what do we have to
preserve in this instance?
Well, if it's the case of
whether we think this fellow's
going to shoplift in the next
12 months with a 99-degree
percent probability, he can
rightly say, I don't even care
about the mumbo-jumbo
of big data.
I'm part of the 1% that's going
to exercise free will,
moral choice, and do
the right thing.
Now of course, all 100 of those
individuals will say the
same argument.
But it does mean that it seems
like we're going to have to
create a new value
in our world.
Just as the printing press gave
us the consciousness of
free speech--
prior to the printing press, we
didn't have a guarantee or
the consciousness
of free speech.
When Socrates drank the hemlock
for corrupting the
youth of Athens, in his
apologia did he make a
free-speech claim?
No.
It didn't exist.
It took the printing press
to give us this idea that
expression was something that
needed to be protected.
What will need to be protected
in a world of big data?
Well, maybe human volition,
free will, responsibility.
We have always had the
risks of data.
We're going to have to deal
with this even more as we
become more respectful of data
and live with it in more parts
of our lives.
We've looked at data
in lots of ways.
America went to war over a
statistic in a data point, and
we saw the problems there.
We're going to need regulators
to think about how we can
adopt this and get the
most benefits of it.
Probably one of the biggest is
going to be giving us a degree
of transparency.
When there was an information
explosion at the beginning of
the 19th century and it was
financial information, we
created accountants to do the
bookkeeping and auditors to do
the surveillance function on
top of the accountants.
And I think that in the future--
and we mention this
in the book--
that we're going to have
to create a new
professional class.
And we might as well call them
algorithmists, who are going
to be trained in big-data
techniques and actually serve
internal to companies, as well
as external in terms of an
expert witness and a master
to a court, that they can
actually understand what's
going on and serve as a
translation function between the
public interest and what's
happening in the mathematics.
For privacy, the shift is
probably going to have to go
from regulating the collection
of data, as we do now in these
preposterous screens of 60 lines
of all-capped letters in
which you just say, I agree with
the terms of service and
not read it, to something
where we
actually regulate use.
And luckily, that seems to be
an idea that is actually
gathering steam.
It's a lot harder for
regulators, but it's
definitely better
for businesses.
And it's definitely better
for consumers.
And of course, we're
going to have to
sanctify human volition.
There is a role for antitrust
regulators, as well.
Antitrust turns out to be an
extremely fertile and fungible
public policy, because it's
technology-neutral.
It doesn't really make many
presumptions about what it's
regulating.
What it does is it just looks
at market concentration.
So it looks like it's going to
be a very useful tool with
which we try to understand what
to do and to create an
open market.
Now there's a problem in this
that I'm laying out, which is
regulators can understand what
scale looks like when it's
something tangible,
like a widget.
Actually, the antitrust came out
of the railroad, so we'll
say a car, a carriage.
And then they applied it to
telephones, and they called it
common carriage.
There's still a Common Carrier
Bureau at the FCC.
The carrier, if you will, was
from the Interstate Commerce
Act where the language
was taken from.
They then applied it to
software markets--
Microsoft.
What does scale mean in data?
What does it mean when the data
is doubling every three
years or so?
What does it mean when the
market is changing form, that
it's not the same market in
five years as it was five
years earlier?
The businesses look different.
It is going to be really
difficult to do, but we're
going to have to
try to do that.
Because we're going to need
the assurances that we can
have challengers as well
as incumbents.
We need both.
This is about the way
that we live.
We're going to need
to act with our
humility and our humanity.
Thank you very much.
There's time for questions,
so shout it out.
There's microphones as well.
Yeah, please.
Go to the mike.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name
is Cynthia Elliott.
I have a question.
So I can see this data being
very useful, like in let's say
drafting of an athletic
player.
Have you ever encountered
anything where colleges would
want you to use this data to
determine who could have the
athletic ability
to be drafted?
KENNETH CUKIER: Yeah, well
colleges and professional
sports are using the data
already right now quite a lot.
The whole book and
movie "Moneyball"
was just about that.
Partially about new statistics
and new ways of examining it,
but then partially just
applying data to it.
And Nate Silver, of course
talks a lot about just
trusting the data
and just doing--
Nate Silver is not
doing big data.
He's just doing data.
He's doing statistics, but the
small difference is he's just
listening to it.
He's just doing it seriously
and trusting it.
So this is going to actually
change lots of the ways that
we evaluate people.
So when we think about students
and education, right
now what a teacher does is it
scores what every person in
the class's grade and tells
everyone, this person got a
95, and this person got an 85,
and this person got a 75.
The teacher doesn't actually
look at what is the content of
the-- or rarely, what is the
content of what was corrected
and what was wrong.
What if that teacher was to
find out that all of the
students in a math exam got
the exact same-- not all.
But let's say 80% of the
students got the exact same
answer wrong with
the same answer.
Suddenly, he or she might say,
hmm, I mistaught it.
They inverted the algebraic
equation thinking that it
could be a or b and b or a.
But in fact, the sequence
matters, and I've got to go
back and teach that.
So not only does the student
learn more, but the teacher
learns as well.
So in terms of drafting, sports
is one of the first
people to adopt these
techniques.
And it's actually changing how
they think about their game.
Certain players--
why would you have a defense
for the opposing team?
You want a defense for who the
player is because of his
propensity to score a shot--
if it's basketball--
from one part of the court
versus another.
If that player on the left side
always misses the basket
there, let him to take a shot.
I'll take it on the rebound
and then pass it up.
Versus oh, don't let this guy
get here into the key.
Then we're really in trouble.
AUDIENCE: With regulation,
I think it's a
very different situation.
Because in the previous
antitrust things, it's been
actually pro-consumer
to limit the amount
of data people have.
There's a reason people go to
Amazon, because they've got
more data and better data
than anybody else.
So in fact if you use antitrust
against there, you
may in fact make life
worse for the
consumers rather than better.
KENNETH CUKIER: That
is absolutely true.
Now the question where this is
going to take us-- and we need
to have a societal conversation
about it-- is
whose data is it?
Whose rights to the
data should it be?
Does the individual own the data
because it's his or her
click stream?
That sounds logical.
But of course, they decided to
go to that website, and that
website invested in collecting
the data and analyzing it.
Should they be required to hand
it over, particularly if
they're going optimize--
let's take Amazon--
their own algorithms so that
they can make great
recommendations.
Why would they want to be able
to give that to the customer
so they can hand it off
to Barnes and Noble?
You're enriching your
competitor.
That sounds almost like
eminent domain.
That sounds like a governmental
takings.
We don't know how to answer
these questions.
But the point here is that
what rights does the
individual have to
his or her data?
Should it be transparent?
Should there be data
portability?
For telephone numbers, we had to
create number portability.
And that seems to be a very good
way to get carriers to
actually love us rather
than to lock us in.
Do we need the same thing in
the world of big data?
I think that your public-policy
people should be
thinking about it.
They probably already are.
And we need to--
and not coming up with answers,
but starting the
discussion and having
the debate.
Please.
AUDIENCE: One of the three
things which you mentioned are
important is mindset.
So you have some framework or
principles that one can follow
and improve on that?
Because that's one thing which
is not as commoditized as with
[INAUDIBLE].
KENNETH CUKIER: Yeah, no.
I don't have any--
there's no simple list or
there's no recommendations I
would put forward.
Because this is sort of about
the spark of creativity.
It's a little bit
da Vinci like.
So I think what is required
is just for very creative
individuals to look at what's
going on around them and
breath the hurly-burly
of humanity and see
the filament of it.
The whole point of Google
was page rank.
But that was just
the algorithm.
The genius was to understand
that every single interaction
with the content gave you
another signal to improve the
search result.
And that was, if you will,
all you need is one
good idea in life.
And if you really go
full-throttle with it-- and
it's a good idea--
it's limitless.
So like Oren Etzioni just had
this idea that I can take
something that nobody
knows the answer to.
But the answer exists.
It's hidden in plain sight.
I can get the data.
And if I do the right thing with
the data, I can actually
transform it and get the insight
that we need and
create new forms of value.
There is no simple way to
develop that sort of mindset.
A lot of it is luck.
There are lots of people that
I know of prior to Oren
Etzioni who had that idea.
There was a company called
Strong Numbers in Boston about
1998 by Jeff Hyatt.
He wanted to be the Blue
Book for everything.
He thought about all
the things that you
could do with data.
He was a little bit too early.
Dot-com bubble burst, and
so did his dreams.
Went on to build other
companies and do
very well for himself.
But it just shows that there's
a lot of factors involved.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So my first question was
actually already answered by
you in terms of who
owns the data.
But more specifically with the
American Express example.
So do you have to purchase
that data from--
not American Express.
American Airlines.
Did he have to purchase the
data, or was he able to gain
access to the data?
KENNETH CUKIER: Great
question.
So the point about American
Airlines was that was the
airline carrier who built the
original airline computerized
reservation network
called Sabre.
So when Oren Etzioni wanted to
get the data, he wasn't going
to go to Sabre.
And the reason why is Sabre is
probably the biggest airline
reservation network, and they
have no incentive to sell it.
Because that's just
not what they do.
So he had to go to one of the
start-ups, one of sort of the
hungrier people that were
the challengers in
there to get the data.
And he found one called
ITA Software.
OK, you see where this
story's going to end.
This is great.
So he goes to ITA Software
and says, will you do it?
And man, they've got a problem
on their hands.
Because on one hand, they need
the data from the airlines,
and this is going to really
screw over the airlines.
On the other hand.
Oren's going to pay them a
little bit of money and give
them a commission.
So they don't know what to do.
So actually, I interviewed--
and they're just a bunch.
Are these airline executives?
No.
These are a bunch of MIT PhDs
and stats who did it because
they thought it was a really
complex problem
and a lot of fun.
So I interviewed one
of the co-founders.
And I said, well,
what did you do?
And he said, well, the truth is
we actually kind of came up
with that idea ourselves
independently
before Oren did it.
And we did it internally just
for fun, but we could never
release it as a product.
Because we just knew it was
going to really harm us.
We'd never be able to get
the data from people.
But this was a way that we could
license the data at an
arm's-length way and still get
a couple guineas for it.
And he had the data.
So it shows you that there's
these competitive interests.
So what happened to
ITA Software?
They were acquired.
For how much?
Between $700 million and
$800 million dollars?
By whom?
By Google.
So why?
Well, you guys can
answer that.
I know that when I do my
searches, I see the airline
listings in, and that's
a great feature.
But I'm sure you're playing a
stronger hand and a lot more
long-term one.
The regulators walked in.
It was one of the real first
substantial essentially
antitrust remedies against
Google on this.
And what it was it was sort of
a must-license provision with
a reporting requirement going
back to the companies, and
essentially to the FTC.
For a period of a couple years--
maybe two or three,
maybe five years--
they couldn't actually cut off
the license that they had with
people like Kayak, et cetera,
because they were afraid you
were going to become the world's
biggest travel agent
and dominate everyone.
But the point here is this.
Think about the sums.
Oren Etzioni's Farecast,
$100 million.
ITA Software, $700 million.
The difference here is that the
algorithm and the skills
is really good, and the service
is really good.
But he who has the data--
that's the gold.
AUDIENCE: Do you see this
societal shifts, particularly
in America?
I think big data and
individualism is a really
interesting area to think about
and whether this changes
the way that we think about an
individual's role in society.
The examples you were giving
of a criminal who is 99%
likely to recommit versus 1%
likely to rebuild his life and
be a productive member
of society.
Hedging for the benefit of
society is to put all 100 back
into jail and leave
them there.
How does this impact how we
think about individual benefit
versus societal benefit?
And does this also play into
future governmental shifts?
KENNETH CUKIER: OK.
So in the case of a
criminal-justice system, let's
have that debate.
Because I think it's not an
easy one, and anyone who
thinks it is doesn't understand
the problem.
If I can tell you with a 99%
degree of accuracy that that
man is going to commit a violent
crime, I would be
remiss from intervening.
And it would look like I'm
almost anti-science if I said,
you know, I just
think that 1%--
we got to give them the
benefit of the doubt.
You just never know.
It just doesn't look right.
So on the other hand, this is
one of the most heinous
affronts to the dignity
of the individual that
we could ever conceive.
And we don't have any experience
thinking through
this issue.
This is so essentially that we
figure it out, that we have
the debate, that the
debate starts now.
Now what about data
for individuals?
What does that mean?
Well, in Athens if you
were a male, you
served in the military.
If you didn't want to sever
in the military, leave.
Right now, we think that one of
the most precious things we
have is data about our bodies,
our health care, our privacy.
Let's change the debate.
Let's change the argument
entirely.
Let's invert the burden
of proof.
Let's just say that if you're
a citizen of a country, you
have to share your data on your
health care in a global
commons so that researchers can
learn from it and treat
everyone's health better.
You don't have to do that.
Leave.
It might sound draconian, but
the fact is do you have a
property right, or some sort of
moral right to your data?
Well, I don't to my image if I'm
walking down the street.
And we do know that I can learn
a lot from the data.
And we also know from stats that
if we allow some people
to back out for whatever
reason, it really
becomes very imperfect.
So suddenly, I think that we
should change the debate.
And I think the most obvious
one would be health care.
But often, when you look at
these issues-- as you've
pointed out to in big data--
these are new issues that
we have for us.
We've had a bit of sloppy
thinking about it lately,
because we haven't had
to deal with it.
And because the whole issue of
big data has been absconded
with by the technology vendors
as the latest flavor of
chocolate ice cream.
But now, let's calm down, and
let's think about it.
The debate should start now.
AUDIENCE: My question is
kind of a follow-up.
So let's assume that
all data is public.
You don't have any
data barons.
How does that influence
the game?
And specifically, humans change
their behavior, and how
does having data that's correct
as of yesterday based
on what I can infer--
I'm sorry--
all of us in [INAUDIBLE] can
infer and predict what we all
of us are going to do
tomorrow if we are
reacting to this data?
KENNETH CUKIER: Yeah.
So yeah, there's a great
circularity that the data is
going to be making
predictions.
We're going to learn about these
predictions, and we're
going to change our behavior
based on those
predictions ever thus.
Right?
This is just going to be
the reality that we're
going to live with.
So in a way, the data will
always be fallible.
You'll never have the
perfect prediction,
because you can always--
this individual will learn that
the algorithms nailed me
for shoplifting before I've
even gone into the store.
I'm not now going to go into
the store, and so the
prediction was wrong.
Now if we arrest him, the
burden of proof is gone.
Because we can never actually
validate the fact the
prediction was going to be
accurate, because we never
allowed him to commit
the crime.
This recursvity--
this weird pernicious circle
in which we're constantly
reacting to the algorithm,
and thereby changing the
prediction that we're making,
is going to be
a feature of life.
And you can imagine that this
is another conversation we
need to have, another thing
we have to think through.
Yeah.
Good.
Thank you very much.
It's been a delight.